ted caution ice carving in progress
a few local ice parts are going under
ice construction today
and rocky checked in with icebar at the
link to see how it's done
yeah first i'm going to show you how
it's not done all right peter let's
trade tools yes let's go rocky
yeah we're gonna just be right up here
we're gonna just texturize it with that
chisel that's made just for the ice okay
what's the technique though
you're just adding texture to it so that
the light can reflect come on up a
little bit we don't have to go as deep
wow not bad not bad so listen when you
guys come down to the ice bar and you
come visit the angel wings right here
know that this was me
i said i should go ahead and carve las
vegas now are eight knees now
in my eyes exactly okay let's move over
here to noelle you're the owner of this
place
whoa it's snowing in vegas the first
question i asked you when i came in here
was where did you find ice carvers in
the desert
you know we've got a team of eight to
ten people that we've been doing
working with for years these guys are at
the top of their trade the best of what
they do
they're winning competitions all over
the world and i'm so fortunate to have
them come with us every year
as we refresh and redo our and reinvent
our our ice attraction
and this is something you guys do
multiple times because
obviously ice melts and you gotta
refresh it it's a perishable product so
it's always changing sometimes it has a
mind of its own you never know what
you're gonna get
but there's a hundred tons of ice in
here and we build it brick by brick
block by block 250 pounds per block hard
work
these guys work 12 hour days making it
done but i'll tell you it's amazingly
beautiful
it is an experience for sure so when you
come down here what is going on
when nice carving is done and it's all
ready so we'll open up at 6 p.m tomorrow
which will be wednesday but
uh you know we are an ice attraction
everything is made of ice we give you
all the gear to keep you warm
the gloves the hats to keep you nice and
toasty when you're coming out of 110
degrees
people come in most people hang out 45
minutes to an hour
they celebrate the art of ice they drink
from these glasses that we have that are
actually made of ice
you know when that ice glass touches
your lip this whole place just comes
comes alive got our golden knights all
wall over here
kind of celebrating the nights uh you
know in the playoffs
go nice everybody you gotta come in here
and make it kind of happen all right go
nice and go ice bar i love it here and i
like this coat i can't i can't take it
all right then i'm gonna hold it in
there i'll send it back to you